there were plenty of times where the
whole crowd was just like oh yeah oh
yeah just
it got so much closer they got us out of
that a lot of clapping there was a lot
of like the first real
like fight scene with shanghai
all right guys so we just got done
watching shang chi and the legend of the
10 reigns um
some people watching the el capitan we
watch with the man's chinese theater
over here
right across the street from each other
upstairs yeah only social media review
embargo lifted so it's one of those you
know quick honest reaction thoughts that
we we can't say anything specific so we
got to be a little bit clever with how
we word everything but we wanted to give
you guys a quick reaction to the film
john why don't you go first i had a
blast watching this movie i will admit i
stepped in with a few expectations or at
least hopes you know i was really hoping
to be wowed by this movie and for the
most part i think they nailed it i mean
they had a lot of really beautiful and
varied fight scenes a lot of different
film styles going in to that just the
heritage of fight scenes on cinema is
clearly inspiring this movie i love just
the cultural flourishes i liked a lot of
the filmmaking flourishes i thought it
was paced pretty well breathed pretty
well and a couple gripes toward the end
that are kind of standard for this kind
of movie but uh for the most part and
i've written that for the most part i
thought they did a nice job making this
feel unique not like just another mcu
movie and i love the cast too yeah you
know it really feels like a live action
anime that's like one of the best ways i
could describe it with flourishes of
like crouching tiger hidden dragon this
gave me the action scenes that i really
really wanted and every trailer reaction
you've ever heard us talk about it is
exactly what i wanted from it and not
only that they escalatingly get bigger
and bigger and like they they get really
big without getting too specific every
action scene that you saw teased in the
trailer is even 10 times cooler in the
actual films itself there were times
where i couldn't even tell like wait a
minute this this tracking shot that
we're seeing is this is this cgi or is
this practical because it looks it looks
like real stunt work for so much of the
crazy stuff like the fight scenes felt
like a combination of like you and wu
ping from like the matrix or crouching
tiger meets jackie chan's fighting style
it was excellent see me lou is or
liu charismatic as hell
really great aquafina really and the
whole cast is really good everyone's
really good in this movie uh but my
favorite out of the whole cast has to
have been uh tony liang as the mandarin
in the movie he brought such pathos to
the role and every time he was on screen
i thought he stole the show the themes
explored with him are some of the best
there's some amazing visual effects in
here i do think that in the way how an
anime can sometimes be so heavy on
dialogue with world building and
exposition
it can feel a little bit bombastic with
that sometimes i was craving more scenes
that had more of like just the emotional
nuance of characters it seemed like it
was so focused on world building for a
large chunk of it there wasn't ever a
scene entirely that i didn't like there
were chunks throughout where i was like
i i would find myself just craving a
little bit more just character-based
stuff instead of just world building
stuff at the same time when you really
view it like a live-action animator like
but it's like a live-action anime you
know you got the flashbacks in there you
got this insane world building some
stuff feels super easy barely
inconvenient but for the most part it
really is a very entertaining film the
last half gives you some real dark
haunting stuff without getting specific
specifically into it what can you tease
that you could possibly say is a little
bit of a qualm that you have there's a
certain element of
cgi spectacle that when you're watching
so many elements collide that you know
are cgi and they're huge and they're
breathtaking and their cacophonous it
starts to become a little bit like
having too much candy that's where it
was
i think you hit the nail on the head
there just to interrupt you really
quickly yeah
it was like towards the last half hour
at least without getting specific was i
think you're doing a little too much now
yeah like it gets so big and it's like
the movie has an epic quality about it
that's another thing i was hoping for is
it does feel hewn-like and epic like you
know a crouching tiger but also with
some elements of you know like a lord of
the rings style epic as well yeah i mean
you've seen some of the trailers like
you know their armies yeah you know at
play and whatnot you know there are
villages you know warring and so like
the stuff that's really tangible the
action that plays closest to the ground
is my favorite stuff the things that go
out into cg i will say like you know the
big spectacled candy coated stuff is
really cool and i think that even the
things i would gripe about i really like
in isolation it's just they affect the
the main core elements of the story and
the plot and the characters in a way
that i think could have been
handled slightly differently and made
more impactful and also i gotta say a
lot of what we thought the plot would be
is not the plot of this movie that's all
i'm going to tell you yeah it's that was
a nice surprise it was a nice surprise a
lot of things i was like this isn't at
all what that's what i thought the plot
would actually be and also i'll say like
the music in this movie was great uh
from like who is the musical artist that
did it the one that was teased in the
trailers recently for the rise up
trailer i forget here's his name on
screen also like just the cinematic
score of it and the cinematography was
excellent too it really does feel
different like of course you have your
mcu tie-ins absolutely but for the most
part i'm like this feels like i'm just
watching a hong kong fantasy flick along
the lines of a hero really quick look we
have this guy holding the camera
probably gonna put him in the thumbnail
but we just gotta get him in we just
gotta get
cosmic wonder made it out to california
just to come to the premiere what are
your honest thoughts in the movie buddy
i loved it and i've come down from i'm
at the premiere so i loved it no matter
what
i truly did love this movie
i had a few qualms like they had but i i
really truly love this movie i think
it's very different from marvel kind of
reminds me what they did for black
panther like it wasn't in the norm
especially like with the music with the
cinematography like it was all visually
beautiful like i loved how it looked
visually i loved pretty much each scene
and the kung fu which i was worried
about is there i was worried it wasn't
going to be there it was going to be
more marvelous than it was going to be
you know like a kung fu movie that's not
the case i think the action was
fantastic i'm the same with greg some of
the scenes i'm like did he do that or
was that cgi i don't know was that a
stunt or was that actually it's gotta be
a combination right yeah i was just kind
of like wow that was fantastic like
literally blown away with the movie i
personally would give it like a nine out
of ten just that qualm about the ending
but i mean the i don't know if you want
me to say this
mid credit scene will blow your mind and
the postcard seems really cool too those
are some engaging post-credits yeah
there's two you got to stick around for
you really got it but those were really
engaging yeah yeah they were insane and
there were other characters in here that
i thought i wasn't expecting to love as
much like the sister oh yeah
oh i'm in love with her yeah she was
great she was amazing uncle finn was
amazing michelle obviously fantastic
everybody was really good but i will say
like with it within every qualm even
with some stuff that we were
kind of being specific about because we
can't be specific even within some of
those calms there were still some great
moments in there that really had us
swept up i think john would have tested
the same thing yeah it was overall i i
loved it i think a lot of people are
gonna love it because it is very
different it ties into everything else
without making it about that that's a
good way to put it yeah it's an exciting
film it is and yeah i think the cra
there were there were plenty of times
where the whole crowd was just like oh
yeah oh yeah just
it got so much
it was thoroughly satisfying sorry guys
had a weird cut there but look all three
of us are
in frame right now uh thank you guys for
watching i do recommend go watch this
movie don't wait for it to go on disney
plus actually go watch this movie in the
theaters if you're ableton if you're
comfortable too please go and do it
subscribe click that bell
follow this guy he's going to have
breakdowns coming for this movie and we
might react to some stuff from his you
know
all right we'll see you guys
[Music]
you